the final season of Showtime's hit TV
series homeland premieres this Sunday
for nearly a decade actress Claire Danes
has portrayed CIA agent Carrie Mathison
Showtime is part of Viacom CBS and the
season premiere Matheson is suspected of
being a double agent after spending more
than 200 days in a Russian prison you
did admit to giving up the location of
the safe house in Beirut yeah one that
hasn't been active for decades
I believe the Pat point I'd been kept
awake for 96 hours what about assets
what about them did you ever reveal the
identity of an asset no maybe somebody
who died 10 years before no assets have
families I wouldn't do that
you sure how much more clearly can I say
this I did not miss Mathison how can you
be so sure if there's 180 days of your
life you don't remember two Emmys for
the role good morning welcome
how does it feel going into the final
seat oh my gosh it's just a lot it's a
lot of feelings a lot of feelings I mean
it's been as you said you know an almost
a decade of my life I was barely married
when we started now you have two kids
you know who we've dragged all over the
planet as we film this thing so maybe
they're happy it's over maybe I don't
know it's just been but it's been a
wonderful gig it's been just the best
experience and I and the quality of
material has been so excellent
throughout and really goodness that
certainly been life-changing for you
Claire because number one she's so
intense and she's so complicated
yeah and very patriotic I know it's
acting I get that but is there a part of
you that thinks that takes on part of
the character it seeps into your DNA how
do you reconcile that it's funny I wish
I knew myself exactly I mean I was able
to I had to compartmentalize right
because she is so loaded yes but but of
course I it's also she's in me on like a
molecular level at the same time
and I've had this imaginary friend is
there a point when you as you as you
start playing a character like that when
you reach a point when you realize she
really is in me now yeah I think you
know I think it'll be a slow shedding
process I don't think it's gonna happen
instantaneously it can't you know
because we've been cohabitating you said
in the beginning you were intimidated by
her darkness well yeah when I first read
that pilot I mean whenever you agree to
do a pilot you have to imagine that it
could be what who ended up being which
is a deep commitment and she seemed like
she was under a lot of duress and she
wouldn't ever not be you know and and
that was daunting but but but I I
eventually loved her company I mean
she's she's tortured but she's also
brilliant moral compass is surprisingly
intact you know so which is what makes
her so interesting I guess part of the
fun too is that you all you all always
talk to real CIA agents just sort of
guide you along and that you know well
that's true that's not so true what did
you come away thinking about their jobs
now that you've been talking to them and
playing this character well I'd say use
them differently um I have a profound
amount of respect for what they do I was
just so moved by the level of their
patriotism
you know how sincere that that was and
of course what do we know about their
failures we don't get to know about all
of their myriad successes and I think
that's a reason why the show has been so
successful so for so long is because we
get a peek into this clandestine world
and we get to spend this intimate time
with these people who who give so much
of themselves and take such insane risks
it was a great actor is going to join
you all join the cast is this next
season last season Hugh Dancy mean you
think about him I don't have any scenes
together you don't
I think is a real blessing because I
don't know how I would have been able to
cope so but you get to watch him then
but it was really cool being able to
visit him on his set and share the show
from him from with him from the inside
out like that I could like clear part of
the fun when you see husband and wives
together you're thinking are they really
looking at each did they have a fight
that morning debate holding hands alone
so you were glad not to have seen always
very good you know oh yes I know that
would have IIIi don't know if I would
have been able to maintain the illusion
you you talk about how much has changed
in these 10 years going back to the
beginning you were you were actually you
were at sort of at a low point in your
career you were thinking about leaving
acting well no not really I done I'd
done a TV movie called Temple Grandin
and I would say one which which was
great and I'm but that was such a she's
a really different kind of character and
I know I felt very stretched as a
performer and after it sort of spoiled
me yeah you know and I couldn't find
another material that was as compelling
and as challenging so I I just waited
until I found something like homeland
which is you know something that I could
really dig my teeth into yeah you got to
show all of your chops have you decided
on your next chapter yet do you know
what if you have any ideas over
it was quite yeah I mean I think it
might hit me in the spring when Woody
we'd be going to shoot the next season
but I'm just really excited to share
share it with the world finally we've
been working really hard on it I'm
really proud of how you have always
gonna say you like out in I feel wraps
up everything for all shape of the
season so yeah now it's the audience's
turn all right congratulations they were
way in notable runs the final season of
homeland premieres this Sunday on
Showtime
you